I guess my question for you is with all
this all let's talk about the world
economic Forum everything they're
talking about doing they want to ban
free speech
based on everything you've read where do
you think the next steps are where are
they going to try and bring us so a lot
of these books do talk about uh 10 20 30
year actuary plans so the next 10 years
is to get in things like the cbdc it's
to get in things like Universal basic
income if people accept it we had you
know the Klaus and then we're running
cyber polygons so and they were just
recently talking about
large-scale uh internet cyber outages I
mean when they run a lot of these drills
not always but a lot of times the drills
you know kind of pre-sage what's going
to come so I would say in the next 10
years we could we could expect that kind
of stuff we're talking about like a
cyber 911 yeah some some great
catastrophe what is that going to look
like you think phrasing phrasing out
bank accounts we saw with the the
airlines they're saying some guy deleted
some files on accident but then we saw
the Bank of America thing where people's
money started disappearing they said oh
it was a glitch if if we actually got
some cyber shutdown
I remember there was this big thing in
the hacker committee people were telling
me about I'm not an expert many of you
listening maybe know it's called DNS
cash poisoning you guys might know about
that apparently there was this big thing
that happened
where uh domain DNS domain was it domain
name servers the the directory for the
internet had some kind of exploit and a
small group convened all the great
Powers the internet and said hey guys if
anyone finds out about this if this gets
out internet gets shut down and so they
secretly worked behind the scenes fixed
the problem and then came out and said
you guys had no idea how close you were
to the entirety of the internet going
down
if something like that were to happen
our economy would be overnight I mean
you you go to these small small cafes
and everything's digital you go to
Starbucks it's like who uses cash
but if the internet goes down you're not
doing transactions with a credit card
credit card will be piece plastic
nothing no way to transact any of this
stuff
I mean that could that would that I mean
I think that's a possibility for what
they may be talking about that's the
problem what's going to be the reaction
what's going to be the solution I think
that's the important thing to really
kind of uh look at here we were talking
about what what's happening with Bank of
America the FAA the Canadian FAA uh a
lot of people are kind of speculating
that there's a big possibility that
these are Ransom attacks it's also
important to note here that a lot of
these Ransom attacks are directly
because and I believe Edward Snowden
said this a couple years ago was that
the CIA and the NSA built specific
toolkits they built specific Online
weapons that could hack a lot of uh
online websites a lot of important key
pieces of infrastructure those toolkits
were just allegedly stolen and now any
hacker could get access to them was this
done deliberately was this something
done that uh was was just a part of a
larger plan here was this an accident
was this done on purpose I think those
are questions that people should be
asking themselves since these larger
Ransom attacks that were in the news a
couple months ago especially affecting
American oriole Supply in the southeast
of the United States
um we paid for these tools kits that are
being used right now for these Ransom
attacks people need to understand that
What's Happening Here was directly a
responsibility of some of the biggest
agencies in Washington DC when were
these toolkits taken
um I gotta I gotta look it up just to
give you a concise answer about this but
I believe Edward Snowden did uh a big
expose you could definitely call it a
form of theft but it's more keep in mind
that they copied those tool sets so now
there's multiple copies of them floating
around it's all out there
future sounds fun and exciting
I don't even know I recommend I remember
I recommend getting out of cities buying
chickens maybe some goats like some
people say we're not even there won't
even be humans in 100 years at that
point I don't know if that's I did it I
did a segment talking about how we will
not be like if population collapses all
of the luxuries you know will be gone
like let me ask you a question how does
that TV up there work
do you know does that does that can
everybody can anybody give me a
fundamental explanation and I can look
at a computer processing a board but I
have no idea what where what copper gets
soldered where and gets twisted onto the
here's what I know the TV that's an LED
light emitting diode they're lined up
they emit colors I got no idea how you
convert you create a graphical user
interface if if the population collapsed
so what we there are people who probably
know how to make a screen an automatic
glass who know how to make a circuit
board that don't know how to make a TV
because it's all of the different
companies coming together that's the
problem with these replaceable Parts
factories in general is that people
don't know the entire process anymore
the artisanal labor workshops is gone
there's a function of reality no one
person can know how to make a toaster
now here's what I did say and and these
left has tried mocking me for it we do
have laymen understanding of certain
things which will benefit us in
rebuilding if population collapsed like
like I don't know how to smelt or
anything like that or or or mine or or
make iron I couldn't make you cast iron
skillet but I do know General things I
was shown by a geologist iron rich or
deposits iron rich mud and where iron
comes from and I have a basic
understanding of melting things down
because we've actually we got a crucible
and a kiln and all that stuff and we've
melted down Metals before but if I were
to try it I'll put it this way
if the society collapsed me here and all
this luxury all this stuff will take me
years to figure out how to make a piece
of metal years now that's better off
than a tribal you know caveman or
whatever took them Generations so there
is that benefit but people understand
how much you will lose if the grid goes
down
to answer your question in it was March
of 2017 Newsweek actually had an article
about this that was titled Edward
Snowden slams NSA over Ransom attacks
and essentially lays out the argument
how the NSA could have prevented a lot
of this but they acted in a way that
allowed these kind of attacks to happen
and to continue to happen when they
could have prevented them and stopped
them but they didn't so it was it an
accident or did they do it on purpose
for me I don't know we don't have the
evidence but I think they did it on
purpose yeah I'm now of the belief that
there is no monolith Within These
Industries within the NSA CIA American
government like there may be one guy in
that department that has a connection to
a CI to a spy in China that's making
calls that seem normal or slightly you
know and then you're like the entire the
entire thing's compromised at that point
I don't know how to how to stop that
never ever it's like globalization is
inevitable the more we are in touch the
more connected we become whether we want
to or not
by the way there's a uh and Rand
dystopian story that's like what you're
talking about where it's like I don't
know a hundred thousand years in the
future and they everything's everybody's
forgotten all the skills yeah and then
somebody like finds in a a cave stash
somewhere like planned so like how to
make something really basic Star Trek
next Generation they go to a planet
where no one knows how anything works
there's an AI that just controls
everything and they're like trust the ai
ai will keep us safe and just does
everything for us and they're basically
the adults are basically children they
couldn't tell you it's magic Logan's Run
have you seen that yeah yeah a long time
ago yeah they keep them young and dumb
they're as kids and then when you hit
age 30 you like float up into this oven
and get cooked because you can't live
beyond 30 right so yeah they have lights
in their hands and as you get closer to
30 it starts turning red and then when
you're 30 it flashes and then Logan's
like I don't want to die and then he
runs away
that's awesome that's where that's where
we're headed something like that
although if you're an elite you know
you'll live forever if you're a pleb
it's like the time machine you know like
the the H2 Wells yeah human civilization
splits into humans humans split into two
different species the smart and stupid
or whatever so we have more locks yeah
yeah that's right I think we'll
inevitably firstly I think that we are
going to evolve the ability to see
different frequencies so that we'll be
able to delineate what's what's natural
and what's artificial when we look at
like robots that are artificial
intelligence that look like humans we'll
be able to actually see that because
when I take psilocybin for instance the
artificial stuff is obviously artificial
the the life forms stand extremely out
so I think we'll redevelop that ability
to witness what's what's natural I don't
agree I think they're going to trick you
I think they're gonna they're gonna
they're gonna find ways to control your
brain and I'm wondering if it's going to
be after 100 Years of enslaved that
people start to evolve this ability to
see
they're gonna put a chip in your brain
that's going to stop you from seeing
what they don't want you to see but you
said you said you were uh vibing with
some cockroaches so maybe are you
already seeing the frequencies
I've seen infrared light when I woke up
out of a dream one day my it was just
whatever my phone it was like light was
like I could see it was just all bright
red and then it like twisted and it went
it looked like it went into the phone
that's just because my perception was
closing around it and I was losing so we
had the ability to see what we maybe
think we can't well there are women who
can see I think what uh UV or is it is
it infrared which one let's see UV I
think right I don't know if it's UV I'm
not I don't remember which one it is but
it's one of those that just see more
colors because there's more
tetrachromats yeah yeah more cones in
their eyes they can see more colors and
it's only women yeah and that uh I guess
they say if you look up when a cloud is
passing over the sun look up and if you
see like purple around the edges your
attention I've seen that before
sometimes my eyes will go in and out of
this bro you can't you can't oh yeah you
can you can see purple around the white
light if you let yourself Ian uh I'm not
mad about it okay I've done it many
times in my life perhaps fine what we
understand about the science is that men
can't be tetrachromax you can see all
the colors of the rainbow in white light
if you let yourself right and
tetrachromats mean they can see colors
you've never seen before yeah because
it's nothing like women were ones who
are hunters and gatherers and or 100
they were gatherers they were looking
for fruit they were looking for uh
things that were safe to eat they'd be
able to determine which was like just
the right shade of green what was the
wrong shade of green because there's so
many plants it looks so similar so over
time women involved the ability to see
things in a particular color men didn't
evolve that because they were Hunters
they didn't need that skill interesting
so I wonder maybe that'll be something
to do with telling if something's alive
or if it's a robot you'll be able to see
a color emanating off of it the other
thing I think we're going to evolve is
the ability to use our psychic abilities
to communicate with our thoughts again
like you know when you call your friend
on the phone and they're they're calling
it's busy because they're calling you at
the same moment I don't think there's
ever had that weird thing happen it's
happened to me many many times like more
than seven times in my life maybe maybe
you know maybe they say that Jenny
mutation could only occur in women it's
because the gene for our red and green
cones on the X chromosome in women F2
men only have one
and if a manage genetic mutation in the
X chromosome and he only has one it will
result in him being colorblind rather
than tetrachromatic whoa no I don't know
that was crazy like the I could see that
if we build up our psychic abilities
better 12 of women psychics 12 that's
crazy psychic's kind of a loaded term
sounds woo-woo but if we figure out how
to communicate without having to rely on
our voices or writing like we'll be able
to bypass technocratic takeover if you
can protect your thoughts and choose
when to have thoughts and when not to
the machine's not going to be able to
read your mind because you have control
of when yo this is crazy look at this
these two pictures one is like a
painting rendition from a tetrachromat
and one is like a like a regular picture
so no you're saying that's what a woman
sees on the left that's what a
tetrachromat sees uh the small
percentage of women I guess 12 yeah 12
percent that's not at all what I see on
them Ian might be confusing it with an
acid trip
what happened I was looking into white
light and then I would see I would start
to see the rainbow staring at the sun it
would like turn into yellow then orange
then red then you know purple then black
then white then blue then green then
yellow then orange then red then purple
then black then white and it was like
out of the black would come white again
and it would keep cycling I'd keep
seeing all these just consider it I
don't know I'm weird you know there was
a lot of weed involved I'm sure but hey
that's part of our our our
what we are as well we have cannabinoids
in our brain our species fed off that
stuff right for for the entire existence
of it as far as we know for way back and
now they tried to cut us off of it yeah
true glass how are you talking about
Terence McKenna I will talks about the
stone ape yeah oh yeah yeah yeah I think
for sure our intelligence has evolved
along with our diet which happens to be
what we call today psychoactives or
whatever caffeine for instance it's a
psychoactive you know if I'm gonna
believe any kind of crazy Theory without
evidence it's going to be that aliens
came and genetically engineered humans
between pigs and monkeys to make a slave
race because that just sounds more fun
and would make a good book
yeah yeah you guys ever hear that that's
like a conspiracy I don't have
conspiracy theory is the right word
because it's not like it's not like a
theory conspiracy theory implies like
humans did a thing together but this is
more just like a weird sci-fi idea they
believe that aliens came to Earth and
needed slaves to mine gold so they took
primates and pigs and hybridized them
and then added alien DNA to make them a
little bit smarter and that's what
humans are and I'm just like yeah that's
a lot to believe dude that's a that's a
big leap from a gorilla ate a mushroom
what do you think about the uh
conspiracy against marijuana from like
the 20s Harry J Ann Slinger are you
familiar with that I mean a little bit
the the pr campaign they did to make
people you know marijuana is bad yeah
can you explain it Jay
well I know from like dope Inc and books
like that that uh you know the British
Empire used drugs as a weapon obviously
you know against China and the drug
lanes that
were formerly controlled by like French
and British intelligence that was just
taken over by the West the Elites in the
West in our country right to run the
drug Lanes so I think that it's really
complex but I think that in regard to
hemp um if you're like I'm from
Tennessee Kentucky area so the history
of Kentucky was that was like a perfect
place to grow hemp and it was a you know
useful for all these different
things and it was uh intentionally
suppressed because certain chemical
companies you know wanted to have
monopolies over things that you know
hemp would put them on a business for so
I don't I don't think it really had
anything to do with the drug effects
they had to do with like the markets and
these these big corporations William
Randolph Hearst with paper newspaper
magnet he had trees on tree farms and he
wanted them to stop using papers is what
I've heard he wanted them to stop using
hampus paper and start using Pepper or
whatever his tree stuff check this out
check this out so this is uh a a
tetrachromacy test
you ever you've done these tests before
I'd imagine where they're like what
number is in the circle and then you got
to read the number but if you're
colorblind you can only see like one
shade it's the same thing by protect
your chromats so I just threw I just see
red green and orange that's awesome I
don't see anything but if you're a
tetrachromat you actually will see the
other colors now I don't know if the if
the monitor screen can emit those proper
colors to be honest but apparently
that's the point they're trying so
chicks is like birds what you're saying
yeah
they eat like birds too they tend to
swallow things holes
are real yeah
and so it says how could it be valid
computer screens only use red green
pixels I can't display the huge
attention permit would be able to see
right pigment and light are different
yeah so it's a fake test it's not
figment is a reflection of light
computer screen's not enough color
information to actually do the real test
ah so hummingbird what I would see is
like an aura around it that would come
out I would see like a purple and then
blue or whatever depending on the
oxygenation levels if you're
deoxygenated it's like more yellow and
the more oxygen you have the Bluer it
gets it seems to it's called that acid
flashback I don't think so I never I
never broke my brain with drugs like I
never went crazy I was always slow to
start and I've never done more than like
I don't know an eighth of mushrooms at a
time but some people like people like I
did multiple acid hits I'm that no
that's not my style that's crazy I don't
know unless you want to do it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time